even Jerry Rice says that this man is
the greatest of all time which says
quite a bit nine seasons in the National
Football League pro ball all nine led
the league in rushing eight times never
missed a single game one of the all-time
greats in American sport history both
collegiate Lee and professional football
Jim Brown Hall of Famer good to see you
sir this person so this is a big day I
did not know this but we found this out
that today Jim Brown was a 40 the
today's the 48th anniversary of the very
day that you had a summit a Muhammad
Ali's summit with Lew Alcindor
you and Bill Russell all part of raising
awareness in local communities back in
1967 June 4th 67 48 years ago today you
are here and this is something that I I
know you're you'd like to speak on
because you're about to do something
else in this room make it simple sure
back in those days those were the top
athletes you know we had about 12 of
them I can't call all the names but the
mayor of Cleveland Carl Stokes the first
black mayor of a major city was also a
part of it and what we wanted to do was
call attention to the fact that Muhammad
Ali could be telling the truth about his
religious beliefs and so we summon him
to Cleveland some of the top athletes at
about five hours with him totally
convinced that he was sincere and then
we're back to 100% and I think that
helped the government take a second look
and later on they dropped all charges
and that was the purpose of this summit
that had well yes that is the purpose to
say that this young man has a right to
his religious beliefs and they're like
conscientious objective objective so why
not you know let him do what he's gonna
do what's not illegal when was the first
time you met Bill Russell because I know
your your people
you know all my life was seen I don't
know when I met him but I know that I
did read an article and one of the major
magazines and I thought it was a
brilliant article that he wrote and I
knew they would be friends and we've
been friends all these years and dear
friends that's my I'm a partner he's a
great man are you gonna do another
summit with him yes he doesn't know it
yet no you might be in the Rich Eisen
show listening audience or viewing
audience I'd be on it has a great mentor
mentor program one of the best in the
world so that's the part of this whole
new summit but Mayor Baraka in New
Jersey is kind of hosted for us and an
old tireless work of maquila Monsieur
teal Michelle is going to be one of our
main guys from developing the community
so we'll have community people famous
people Ray Lewis of course as one of our
great motivators low blow uncheck me he
doesn't know it I'm gonna be calling on
so it's gonna be an upbeat thing but we
have to stop the violence in these
neighborhoods because in epidemic now
going on in the country and it's mainly
black young male youth on black young
male youth and no one's been able do
anything about it so far so we're hoping
to bring that murder rate down and to
reexamine our schools from the
standpoint of a quality education for
all of our young people so education and
lack of violence in our neighborhoods
and then ultimately the jobs that we
have to try to create and be
conscientiously creating them because
people need to work here at Jim Brown on
the Rich Eisen show and athletes of
today people who would be the equivalent
in terms of status of you and the rest
of the esteemed gentlemen we referred to
although you know there's a galaxy and
then there's a zip code because there's
different time but that said players
today don't really speak out on social
issues and the ones that do run into
quite a lot of flack on social media
which I know you're
as well or at other places basically
saying stick to sports I watch my sports
to avoid thinking about the real world
where do you stand on this subject Jim
certainly with the athletes of today
well you really put that well and that's
brilliant where you did that
conscientiously that's true but it's
always special people that step up so
when I talk about Curtis Martin I give
you a name Jeff a conscientious young
man that wants to help
when I say Ray Lewis Ray Lewis is one of
the greatest motivators in this country
he did it for the Ravens for all these
years and now he's a part of this whole
movement so I say to the young people
that have the money and have the
influence you must step up there's an
epidemic and we're going to put a
situation together that you can step up
and you're gonna be supported by
like-minded people and there are a lot
of them a lot of young people in fact
when you talk about the quarterback of
Cleveland Johnnie to see Johnny go into
rehab and admit that he needs help
there's a great thing because very few
individuals who need help will ever
admit it so you have some great young
people that will step up if they are
given the right leadership because a lot
of my leaders themselves they just don't
know how to really make it work when
they're agents and managers are telling
them how to make the money I'm here with
Jim Brown on the Rich Eisen show let's
talk about Johnny Manziel right now one
of the quarterbacks in Cleveland there's
Josh McCown sitting there and everybody
believes that it's gonna be his gig to
lose based on Manziel having still
trouble grasping what it's like to be a
professional maybe off the field or
certainly on it where do you stand on
Johnny Manziel viability as a future
quarterback of the Cleveland Browns
right now Jim Brown well the first thing
I have to do and I think you might have
to do a two-weeks we have to realize
that we didn't scout him in college and
we didn't draft him someone drafted him
and that person is supposed to have an
expertise on town
because he was there at the pretty high
so I'm gonna rely upon the expertise of
those people at least until Johnny gets
a chance to demonstrate whether he can
do it or not I'm pulling for him and I
recognize with his type of profile
people will pick on him and then with
his attitude he might call some of that
to bear so but bottom line I think he's
a nice young man I think yes Talent and
I think he needs an opportunity to prove
himself have you spoken to him recently
only saying hello I hate to be one of
the guys that's got to answer for Johnny
but what I guess what would you say no
that wouldn't mean that you're you have
any ownership of his actions or belief
system but what would you say to Johnny
Manziel Jim first of all I would
encourage him because for him to accept
rehab it's a big step so many people out
there need to take note not sure able do
it by yourself and I would say to him he
be a professional and be honest with the
game
the truth of the game be a professional
be true to the game don't take the money
and run it's not about the money it's
about the way that you dedicate yourself
to performing on the field entertaining
the fans being true to who you're
supposed to be and do that as strong as
you can and you know the incident that
that recently happened that was
discussed on the internet social media
Mike Pettine the coach said it's much
ado about nothing involving a fan coming
up to him and the reaction that came
from Johnny and his friends I'm sure
you've been on the business end many
times of fans heckling you in one way
shape or form how do you as a
high-profile athlete or back in the day
or advice you'd give to Johnny now for
this steak handle something like that
well you said I profile athlete you know
they're high-profile athletes and
they're high-profile individuals then
they're guys that are just individuals
I'm just an individual I never left the
ghetto I never left the black
neighborhoods I live with the people and
I don't be with bodyguards intimidation
I invite people to my home I invite
gangbangers to my home I invite anyone
to my home I share my life with them but
I don't take any mess when you share
things with people you don't have to
take mess
but I mean not taking mess sometimes
will somebody else nap a picture someone
will tell a story and then it may not be
either the truth or something that you
not taking mess in private suddenly
becomes a public matter Jim well I mean
if I had to complain about that I'd be
sitting here for another hundred hours
I've been involved in all kinds of
things
maybe you forgotten but I was probably
one of the most controversial at least
young men that's ever come along as
[ __ ]
oh I have not forgotten oh good I
remember that so they you know they had
me doing all kinds of things some of
them might have been true but most of
them were not true okay I didn't have no
they're the perfect life but I've always
been an honest person and I live within
myself I have a spirit that carries me
and that's the reason I don't have
bodyguards when I have 400 gangsters at
my home because somehow that spirit
reaches out to people and they can feel
that you care about them and most people
if you care about them they'll respond
properly
I've got Jim Brown here in studio we're
gonna take a 60-second break I gotta pay
a bill
that's okay okay and when we come back
more with Jim brownie four for 204 rich
if you want to ask a question of Jim
that's what we do so I try to be a man
of the people in whatever way I can
folks out there want to call in I'll
connect you with Jim Brown let you into
our home here
and one minute's time
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show much
is being made of next year's 50th
anniversary of the Super Bowl ten days
after that fiftieth anniversary it will
be the 80th birthday of my in-studio
guests and the 50th anniversary of his
retirement from the game at age 30 Jim
Brown here on the Rich Eisen show can
you believe it's been that long
Jim well only when I'm walking upstairs
jump up those stairs
how is Muhammad Ali doing Jim well
Lonnie is a fantastic person she would
just left them and he was there as a
trooper mm-hmm but his health wasn't too
good as far as my observation and but
he's still a trooper and Lonnie and the
people around him dealing with him
properly I think and he's representing
well even in the state of you know the
medical decline that I think he's going
through and what when when somebody
wants to know about Muhammad Ali what
should what should that person be told
who never maybe saw him fight doesn't
know much about his story but we'll know
then he's the great virtue is the
greatest short sentence sure whatever he
likes white people to see why would you
use that sentence to describe Muhammad
Ali Jim because he was criticized for
being a Muslim black Muslim the Muslims
have always been criticized of not
liking white people and in so many cases
that was true in some in case it wasn't
true Muhammad Ali was a Muslim he hated
the atrocities that was causing the name
of whiteness but he did not have the
attitude about good people that would
make him be negative towards white
people that were good black people have
a good see he had a category of good
people that was bright white whoever you
were if you were good you
muhuali would pick it up and so I know
I'm not gonna have too much time on the
show so I picked that particular
sentence because very seldom do we talk
about that and very seldom do we give
the white people that's fall for us in
history do to free us from slavery to
the Underground Railroad led by her to
me
we don't say those things we complain
about the police now and we don't tell
the whole story about the police now one
of my best friends was a policeman Steve
Adams now is one of my best friends he's
an ex-policeman hmm so we take the
shortcut the media shortcut and we throw
things out there without giving it a
balance so what I'm saying to you this
morning is that there's a balance
Mohammed II was Muhammad Ali was a not a
hater he was a good man but he hated
slavery he hated discrimination and he
fought his butt off to eliminate that
but on the other hand if you came to my
home and brought under white people Ali
would probably crack jokes all day Jim
Brown here on the Rich Eisen show I'd
like to take a couple phone calls if
that's okay we're gonna take one from
Cleveland and this is a guy who calls in
the show every now and then Don from
Cleveland Ohio you're on the Rich Eisen
show with Jim Brown Don hello rich and
thank you once again for making dreams
come true oh you best kind of so for mr.
Brown sir if I may ask one question what
was the greatest influence or who was
the greatest influence in your life I'm
becoming the person that you became
Thank You Don for the call Jim thank you
so much for that call because I'm gonna
do a book about that the great people I
knew my high school coach ed Walsh was
the man that influenced me mostly it was
a great man great human being and
without him I don't think I ever would
have been anything because I had no
father and my mother was struggling
and he even offered my mother to let me
live with him if you know she wanted
help and so I'm so glad I can say that
because he's passed now but he was a
great man at watch hmm
my high school clothes and when you look
back now that were like a next you'll be
the fiftieth anniversary of your
retirement what were you thinking at age
30 saying I don't want do this anymore
oh well it wasn't a negative thing at
all it was I saw too many champions go
out the wrong way Joe Lewis you know
come on it was a tremendous champion but
to see him get knocked out of the ring
and crawling through the ropes there's
not the greatest thing what you want to
have of a champion like that I always
wanted to be bold and brazen so you know
to do that you had to finish it as MVP
of the league in your last year and say
I'm going Holly I'm gonna go to
Hollywood and make movies with Raquel
Welch you mean so there was no Raquel
Welch in the National Football League
essentially is what you love it Don in
Harrisburg Pennsylvania you're on the
Rich Eisen show with Jim Brown famous
Eisen I apologize as a loner at school
at work I'm talking to the great
all-american midfielder from Syracuse
mr. Brown I have a lacrosse question for
you if you don't mind no not at all go
ahead took question one what is your
opinion on the sport of lacrosse
secondly what are your thoughts on just
the expansion of the sport especially
what Bill Tierney is on Mount Denver in
this past six years I know in Harrisburg
I started 20 years ago as a player and
now as an assistant coach the sport has
just exploded and I'll let you deal with
that sir well so you
part of the Brotherhood the cross
players around the world we're a
brotherhood a lot of people didn't know
about us for years but we loved the game
and it's a great game Native American
game decided Wars by playing lacrosse a
game and still in killing each other box
lacrosse you go on a reservation and
play with the Indians tremendous
background played a part in my life and
I love it my son now is playing it and
he didn't even know I played No did you
tell them what did you tell him you're
pretty darn good out here in all that
stick and I was gonna try to show him
but it didn't work Dino in Rochester New
York you're on the Rich Eisen show with
Jim Brown Dino I don't mr. Brown a
pleasure to speak with you thank you but
I was wondering if you could elaborate
on your relationship with Al Davis of
what your thoughts were on him and my
opinion he's on the Mount Rushmore of
the NFL and what can you elaborate on
the 1983 Sports Illustrated cover when
you appeared in a Raiders uniform do you
know I love though he was a friend of
mine it would call me to have dinner so
we could talk over things and I guess
when they put him in the Hall of Fame
where they were gonna put him in the
Hall of Fame he said Jim you know
they're messing with me now because they
know that they put me in a Hall of Fame
I can't say the same things I used to
say he was a true sportsman one of a
kind highly controversial but I think a
really a good man and a very visionary
person so I have nothing but the
greatest person respect for Al and his
family and they were right a Raiders
Jersey on the cover sports all that that
cover yeah well I'll see that's why you
have to think and they were talking
about me coming back so I decided to get
some publicity out of it
so I said if I'm coming back they're the
only team that I would come back and
play for your Raiders because the only
president that would understand it and
then I get along with David I love it at
Jim Brown is here would you mind staying
for one more second no no terrific
because I want to ask you about it I
want to ask you about a current NFL
topic this deflategate thing I got to
get your thoughts on that and then a
quick thought on the Cavs and what it
would mean to the city of Cleveland not
a championship but Jim Brown right here
when we come back on the Rich Eisen show
on for the TV audience I got to ask you
about the Dirty Dozen that has to happen
that's good very good that's next here
on the rich awesome
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show Jim
Brown here on the program the Dirty
Dozen when you hear that movie name what
do you what what's your recollections of
being on the set shooting that movie Jim
I was privileged they had one of the
greatest cast of all times
led by Lee Martin mm-hmm I mean Donald
Sutherland Jon Cassar Beatty's would go
on and on and on it's book night and it
was just a tremendous experience for me
I was the rookie guy they could have
blown me off the set but they took me
under their wings and helped me and I
gave a decent performance because of
that no really because of that because
of all of that and I had sense enough to
recognize that if it had been other
circumstances I probably have had a
miserable performance but Bob Walters
was our director mm-hmm and I think Bob
would probably be the only director that
could handle that group because not only
were they talented they were crazy off
the set off off set off on stir like his
hair is a safe for work story oh I don't
know
tell us about us would be a good I think
and down so and also would I better lay
back Lee Marvin had a unknown problem
but his soon-to-be wife made sure that
he got to the set on the first falla
morning when she recorded an adventure
Lee Marvin oh yeah that was weird maybe
the country finally heard the word
palimony and that scene were you
dropping the hand grenades just running
along yeah I mean didn't make it well
how many somebody takes that one so why
does it hit that cement so I did it once
you out and get the cement and that mess
car so once you got hurt yeah I got I
was hurting
there's a difference yeah you know
what's that they say there's a
difference between being hurt and
injured that's what they say yeah Jim
Brown is here we're back with more one
last segment with the go p-- Jim Brown
right here on the Rich Eisen children
the Hall of Fame running back Jim Brown
here on the Rich Eisen show I'm gonna
hand things over quickly I've just not
only the fence that we just had but
Chris Brockman and Chris law have a
question for you h Brockman you are a
Syracuse grad this is number 44 right
here I am and here he is mr. Brown the
university decided recently to bring
back number 44 for the football program
you reportedly gave your blessing why is
now the time to do that and what are
your thoughts on the program direction
well boy you guys yeah I didn't exactly
give my blessings I just didn't complain
I didn't talk to anyone before they
decided to do it so they couldn't have
my blessings but when I did get a call
from an executive up there I didn't make
a fuss about it and I told him whatever
you want to do was okay with me so it's
okay with me you know but if they had
asked you what would you said no because
it sounds like you you do have a little
bit of well you want to attack you
unretire something and there has to be a
commercial aspect to it so if it's going
to help the team the school commercially
helped the scholarship fund or something
like that then it's good but for me to
endorse something that takes away
something from you doesn't make sense
unless I did something to deserve it it
seemed like a punishment to me but I
don't take it that way but it couldn't
be a positive thing
unless someone explained it where all of
us would see the the positive aspect of
it interesting I got about five minutes
left you want to question real quick
well obviously Jim Brown legend greatest
football player of all time
during the 60s there was another man
with the exact same name James Brown The
Godfather of Soul did you ever meet
James Brown well absolutely
followed the ADA loved it
James is a friend of mine he was from
Georgia and one of the Great's of all
times
I think we should probably leave it yeah
Jim Brown here on the Rich Eisen show
before I let you go deflategate what do
you think about this you know I don't
think about that
because there's never going to be
absolute proof of a conspiracy mm-hmm
and frankly I don't care if the ball is
10 pounds or 12 pounds or 40 pound or
whatever that's that's one you're
talking about right that's the one I'm
talking about and I know and I know that
you you're you're friendly with Bill
Belichick correct absolutely
and and is it true that when Bill
Belichick finds a player in New England
the money that he collection of players
goes to American is that a true story oh
well that was in the past and you know
when it was back in those particular
days he has donated to our organization
he has come to our fundraising events
he's always there if I called him he's a
great man you know and no one's gonna
ever tarnish anything as far as me
understand him through his greatness he
is a great man
well the nickname for him is modern-day
Lombardi would you agree with that
assessment well I'd have to think about
it and I don't have time on show but I
would say that he is similar to Lombardi
and their ability to be convinced their
conviction their dedication to the game
the things that they demand of you yeah
they're similar in those ways no doubt
about it
who's the one running back on
on a Sunday a Thursday night or a Monday
night current right now that you would
want to watch run the rock which one
well my guy Adrian would be the Adrian
Peterson would be the guy he's got the
hard there to and the size speed
strength have you spoke to have you
spoken him lately with what's been going
on with him Jim no I don't try to be a
doctor everything some things that get
in to that and when I have real point of
view but in his case is so complicated
until I just want him in his family know
that I'm I'm his friend and I know he's
trying to do the right thing and I'd be
remiss if I did not ask you about the
city of Cleveland's basketball team that
takes to the court in Northern
California tonight in the 1964 Browns
the last team to deliver a major sports
championship to Cleveland
I've got about a minute left what would
it mean to it look like that is gonna
come to an end this team but they have
the ability to do it LeBron is a rare
human being unselfish unselfish to the
tee understand things way beyond his age
and the other players seem to understand
that now so I was worried earlier but I
think they get it
so Cleveland might be living forward to
a new champion what would that mean to
the city it would mean a lot to that
city because they have suffered through
so many years of things they did not
cause because they did their job they
came to the games they cheered and they
were great fans and then known across
the world as great fans so fans in
Cleveland stay with stay with it
LeBron lead him to the victory and let's
forget about the 64 championship team
yeah we got enough credit already yeah
Jim I cannot thank you enough for taking
the time to spend so much time with us
in the studio today sure thank you and
your father okay okay he's given a
shout-out to the coconuts right here
that's nuts that that is is that is a
great as great a moment as those two
guys have had and
thank you I mean seriously nice
community we love you because the number
of you the number of guests that we've
had to look over there and say what are
those to do here now that you've come in
and said something good hang out James
Brown stories off the I love it Jim
Brown NFL 32 on Twitter American is this
vans program look it up thank you Jim
appreciate you you bet the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience